GOOD WORK ON THE STREETS OF
CARACAS, THANKS A LOT.
AND NOW FOR OUR EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS LIVE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT APPEAR
TONIGHT APPEAR >> THANK YOU
, AND GOOD EVENING.
WE JUST FINISHED 20 MINUTES OF
SIT DOWN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE COVERED A WIDE VARIETY OF
TOPICS, INCLUDING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
EMMA WHO REFUSED GO TO THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON THE BASIS
THAT HE WOULD TAKE QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE STAFF LAWYERS.
HE ALSO ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER HE WOULD ALLOW THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DOM
BEGAN TO TESTIFY TO CONGRESS.
HERE IS PART OF THE INTERVIEW.
>> I'VE HAD HIM TESTIFYING
ALREADY FOR 30 HOURS.
>> IS THE ANSWER NOW?
>> I DON'T THINK I CAN LET HIM
AND THEN TELL EVERYONE ELSE YOU
CAN, ESPECIALLY HIM BECAUSE HE
WAS A COUNCIL.
THEY'VE TESTIFIED FOR MANY
HOURS, ALL OF THEM PEERED AT
MANY, MANY
ONE CAN AND THE OTHER CAN'T.
>> SO IT'S DONE?
>> I WOULD SAY IT'S DONE.
NOBODY HAS EVER DONE WHAT I'VE
DONE.
I'VE GIVEN TOTAL TRANSPARENCY.
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE LIKE
THIS.
>> CONGRESS SHOULD BE --
>> THEY SHOULDN'T BE LOOKING
ANYMORE.
THIS IS ALL.
IT'S DONE.
EVEN MY FINANCE -- THEY MUST'VE
BEEN LOOKED AT 4:30 $5 MILLION.
I ASSUME
THEY LOOKED AT MY TAXES.
I ASSUMED MUELLER LOOKED AT MY
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS, HAVING 20
PEOPLE AND 49 FBI AGENTS AND ALL
OF THE STAFF AND ALL THE MONEY
THAT WAS SPENT, I ASSUMED THEY
LOOKED AT MY TAXES, WHICH ARE
FINE.
EXCEPT, THEY ARE UNDER AUDIT, BY
THE WAY.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT OFFICIALLY.
>> THEY ARE COMING DOWN ON YOU
PRETTY HARD.
>> I'M GOING TO COME AFTER
TRUMP, CAN YOU IMAGINE SO MANY
CAMPAIGNING WHO DOESN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT ME QUESTION
ACTUALLY IS IS CAMPAIGNING ON
THAT FACT.
I ASSUME FOR THE $35 MILLION, MY
TAXES, MY FINANCIAL STATEMENTS,
WHICH ARE PHENOMENAL, THEY'VE
GONE THROUGH ANYTHING.
AND I'M SO CLEAN.
THINK OF IT, TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AND ALL THAT MONEY SPENT,
NOTHING.
VERY FEW PEOPLE COULD HAVE
SUSTAINED THAT.
>> HE ALSO WENT ON AT LENGTH
ABOUT ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR SAYING IT WAS HIS CALL TO
DECIDE NOT TO GO AND TESTIFY
TODAY BEFORE THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, AND HE MADE THE POINT
THAT HE FELT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS BEING
TREATED DIFFERENTLY OR UNFAIRLY,
IF YOU WILL.
WE ALSO ASKED HIM ABOUT
VENEZUELA, AND SPECIFICALLY, IF
THERE WAS A PHYSICAL THREAT FOR
JUAN CUETO, OR IF HE WAS
DETAINED, HOW THE U.S. WOULD
RESPOND.
HERE IS THAT SECTION.
>> HE IS ACTUALLY A BRAVE
PERSON, AND BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
HE IS GOING THROUGH, I'M
SPEAKING TO MY PEOPLE ALL THE
TIME, HE IS A BRAVE GUY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN VENEZUELA IS
SAD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT 20 YEARS AGO,
ONE OF THE WEALTHIEST COUNTRIES
IN THE WORLD, IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT.
NOW THEY DON'T HAVE FOOD, THEY
DON'T HAVE WATER, PEOPLE ARE
DYING FROM HUNGER, IT'S A VERY,
VERY SERIOUS SITUATION.
>> WHAT ARE YOUR REDLINES IN
VENEZUELA?
>> I DON'T WANT TO SAY, BUT WE
HAVE LOTS OF OPTIONS AND SOME OF
THEM ARE TOUGH OPTIONS.
>> IS THERE A TIPPING POINT FOR
MILITARY INTERVENTION?
BECAUSE THERE IS ALWAYS A
TIPPING POINT BUT I WOULD RATHER
NOT DO THAT.
I JUST WANT TO HELP THE PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE ARE DYING.
THEY HAVE NOTHING.
IF THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE
LIVING WELL 20 YEARS AGO.
THEY HAVE NOTHING.
THEY DON'T HAVE WATER AND FOOD.
AND THEY ARE DYING OF HUNGER
RIGHT ON THE BORDER.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> WE ALSO ASKED THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THE 2020 RACE, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HAS
ENTERED THE FIELD,
SENATOR BENNET, AND THE
PRESIDENT HAD SOME SURPRISING
ANSWERS ON HOW HE THINKS THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD IS SHAPING UP
IN WHO HE THINKS HE MAY FACE
ABOUT 18 MONTHS FROM NOW.
>> HE'S NOT GOING TO WIN.
I THINK JOE BIDEN SEEMS TO HAVE
A LEAD.
I WOULD BE VERY HAPPY IF IT WERE
BIDEN.
SLEEPY JOE.
>> WHY?
>> I THINK HE DID A BAD JOB, I
WOULD BE RUNNING AGAINST --
>> YOU THINK HE IS BEATABLE?
>> I JUST DON'T THINK HE WOULD
BE A VERY GOOD CANDIDATE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
YOU KNOW, I WISH HIM WELL.
I WOULD LIKE THEM TO GET IT.
I WOULD BE HAPPY.
I WOULD BE HAPPY WITH BERNIE.
I PERSONALLY THINK IT IS THOSE
TWO.
>> BETWEEN THOSE TWO?
>> I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE.
IN MY CASE, I ANNOUNCED, AND I
WAS PRETTY MUCH -- I KNOW I WAS
AT THE TOP FROM THE BEGINNING.
I THINK HE IS NOW LEADING.
BERNIE WOULD BE SECOND, WE WILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> WHO WOULD YOU RATHER FACE?
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
THAT.
I DON'T THINK IT MATTERS VERY
MUCH.
WE HAVE THE STRONGEST ECONOMY
WE'VE EVER HAD.
WE ARE DOING PHENOMENAL.
WE HAVE THE BEST UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS.
EFFORT      AFRICAN-AMERICANS, A
EFFORT      AFRICAN-AMERICANS, I
EFFORT      AFRICAN-AMERICANS, N
EFFORT      AFRICAN-AMERICANS, ,
EFFORT      AFRICAN-AMERICANS, T
EFFORT      AFRICAN-AMERICANS, E
BEST NUMBERS WE'VE EVER HAD.
WOMEN, THE BEST NUMBERS WE'VE
EVER HAD.
JOB NUMBERS, WEALTH NUMBERS
APPEARED AT THE BEST
ECONOMY WE'VE EVER HAD.
AND MORE PEOPLE WORKING RIGHT
NOW THAN THE     IN THE HISTORYH
NOW THAN THE     IN THE HISTORYE
COUNTRY.
>> JOE BIDEN SAID CHINA IS "NOT
COMPETITION FOR US IN THE U.S.
">> WHICH VICE PRESIDENT?
>> VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
PARDON ME.
>> MIKE PENCE WOULD NOT HAVE
MADE THAT STATEMENT.
EVERYONE IS COMPETITION.
>> IS HE BEING NAIVE ABOUT
CHINA?
>> HE IS BEING VERY NAIVE ABOUT
CHINA.
AFTER I SIGNED THE BILL, THERE
WON'T BE ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
CHINA, DURING THE OBAMA YEARS IN
PARTICULAR, JUST TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF OUR COUNTRY SO BADLY.
VERY, VERY BIG COMPETITION,
CHINA.
I'VE STOPPED IT.
AND I AM STOPPING IT.
OVER THE COURSE OF TWO AND A
HALF YEARS, WE'VE GONE UP
$17 TRILLION IN VALUE.
CHINA HAS GONE DOWN TO
$17 TRILLION.
THEY HAVE TAKEN A VERY, VERY BIG
HIT BECAUSE OF THE TARIFFS, AND
EVERYTHING ELSE I'VE IMPOSED.
FOR SOMEBODY TO BE SO NAIVE AND
SAY CHINA IS NOT A PROBLEM, IF
BIDEN ACTUALLY SAID THAT, THAT
IS A VERY DUMB STATEMENT.
>> WE ALSO ASKED THE PRESIDENT A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
NEXT PHASE OF THIS RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS THE
GENESIS OF THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO 2016, AND HE
TOLD US HE EXPECTS
DECLASSIFICATION OF THESE RUSSIA
RECORDS -- THE SURVEILLANCE
WARRANT APPLICATIONS.
HE INTIMATED WEEKS, MAYBE A
COUPLE OF MONTHS, BUT IN EFFECT,
THAT IS COMING SOON.
I ALSO ASKED HIM TO ADDRESS AN
EDITORIAL IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," AN OPINION
PIECE BY THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
WHERE HE CALLED THE PRESIDENT
"AMORAL," AND CLAIMED IT RUBBED
OFF ON THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT IF HE
WOULD TAKE A DIRECTOR COMING OUT
OF THE EQUATION, IF YOU WILL,
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS,
WHETHER THE COUNTRY WOULD REALLY
BE IN THE SAME PLACE.
THE PRESIDENT ESSENTIALLY SAID
THAT HE FELT THAT DIRECTOR COMEY
SHARED A LOT OF THE BLAME FOR
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND THE
DIVISION, IF YOU WILL, IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Mike: FASCINATING
CONVERSATION.
CONGRATULATIONS, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.